el líder opositor aleccionaban y puede
pasarse otros diez años preso por
extremista el líder disidente lleva en
la cárcel desde el pasado mes de febrero
y podría sumar una década más de prisión
después de que el comité de
investigación de rusia haya abierto un
nuevo caso penal contra él y contra ocho
de sus aliados más cercanos la mayoría
de los cuales por cierto ya han huido
del país el líder disidente junto con el
ex jefe de su oficina y con el ex
director de su fundación anticorrupción
la famosa efe bk están acusados de crear
y liderar una plataforma que está
prohibida en rusia desde el pasado mes
de junio navalny que fue encarcelado en
febrero con una pena de dos años y medio
por delante podría afrontar hasta 10
años de cárcel extra por dirigir esta
red considerada extremista que creó en
el año 2014 las autoridades rusas le
acusan de intentar cambiar los cimientos
del orden constitucional del país y de
socavar también la seguridad pública y
la integridad estatal
federación de rusia creando una
comunidad considerada extremista y
liderando la junto a sus compañeros